ANDREW GERRAND: Good morning
everyone, and welcome to the
session, Go In Production.
This morning I've invited four
members of the Go community,
and people who use Go in their
companies, in production
systems to talk to you about
how they use Go, and their
experience with using Go.
And so without further ado, and
the format of this panel
is that we'll have four short
presentations from the
panelists, and then I'll open
the floor to questions.
And we'll have about half an
hour worth of questions.
During each of the slides, there
will be a little link in
the bottom left corner,
which will be to a
Google moderator link.
So if you want to enter
questions there as you think
of them during the talks,
that's also a good idea.
So without further ado, I'll
invite my first panelist.
He believes that the world needs
better software, and he
works at Canonical currently,
where he
works on the Juju project.
And he's also built Landscape
and the Storm ORM.
And as a Go contributer and a
member of the Go community,
he's worked on the Go core and
the Mango, MongoDB driver,
Gocheck, [INAUDIBLE],
and others.
Please welcome Gustavo
Neimeyer, thank you.
GUSTAVO NIEMEYER:
Thanks, Andrew.
And thank you very much as
well for the Go team for
inviting me to talk to you and
have a chance to describe why
we believe Go is a better
language for our workloads.
Juju, I'm going to quickly
describe what problem we're
trying to solve.
And then I will describe how
we're solving it, and then
I'll go and tell few bits about
why Go is helping us in
those tasks.
So imagine you wanted to
develop, to deploy a service
with a couple of, let's say a
couple of softwares, right?
Either you have a database
and your
application, for instance.
And you're doing that with a
tool, sometimes with the help
of a tool, or by hand.
So it usually goes like that.
You've got a couple
of machines.
You give them some names, and
you develop some affection for
those machines.
And you put configuration files
into those machines.
Those configuration files
generally will have details
such as the IP address for your
database, and information
for exposing that service and
the deals to interconnect to
those machines.
If you think about that, what
you're actually doing is that
you're creating a topology of
services so that the things
communicate with each other.
But what's occurred to us, which
is really interesting,
is that in most cases that
topology is actually in the
administrator's head.
You don't have that in
the system itself.
So this is all good, but then
some issues started to occur.
For instance, it became a
bit hard to give names.
Can you imagine, for instance,
giving like 600,000 names in
the [INAUDIBLE]
morning?
It's a bit tragic as well,
because things, when you start
to get a lot of resources,
whatever those resources are,
even if just a few are failing,
you start to get lots
of failures and you have
to deal with those.
So the topology in that
case becomes a little
bit complex as well.
It's harder to get
things together.
It's hard to keep in your mind
what's actually happening in
the system.
So this is really what
we were after.
We wanted to see not only how to
solve this problem, but how
to enable people to collaborate
while doing so.
And to collaborate, you have
to re-use, you have to
understand how to manage
those resources.
This is what Juju is about.
When we were planning the
system, we very much has the
use case in mind.
How can we implement that in a
very straightforward workflow?
We think a little bit about
it, as like a [INAUDIBLE]
services.
You basically, for instance,
Juju bootstrap, it not only
deploys the service itself,
but it deploys the servers
that run the service.
And then you deploy a couple of
services, just so you know,
deployment application
MongoDB for instance.
And it will actually get those
systems running on a service,
on a machine being managed.
OK, but how do I tell the system
that those two servers
are communicating?
We explicitly say add a
relation between them.
And the bits that are composed,
the services, the
charms, as we call them that
compose the system, they have
knowledge about how
to establish
that relation, right?
So since that knowledge is
within the system you can
start to do tricks, like very
easily add GNU new units.
You can add new bits to the
system, and the system knows
how to interconnect those bits
to the rest of the system.
Where is the topology
in that case?
It is inside.
The system knows what's
going on.
Those bits are reusable, they're
independent, and they
are exchangeable so that people
can deploy a better
MongoDB deploy bits of those
systems, and everybody in the
community benefits from that.
So we're porting everything
to Go.
It was originally made in
Twisted, in Python with
Twisted, and we're porting
the whole system to Go
for quite a bit now.
And we already have base work
in production, such as the
database, the service, the
services themselves are served
from, they're all
running from Go.
So why are we doing that?
There are a few reasons.
One of them, for instance,
is error checking.
One of the beautiful things
about Juju, and the thing that
really attracts people is
that it's kind of a
magic system, right?
You just type some commands,
and whoah, I
have a service running.
But magic systems can also
break magically.
This is a very sensitive
subject, right?
We want things to be running.
We want people to not have
to go after the issues
and the bugs then.
We want to reduce the
chance at least.
It's going to happen, but we
want to reduce the chance of
that happening.
Go gives us a very visual way to
say here you have an error,
do something with it.
Another very interesting point
for us was the fact that, for
instance, when we requested a
watch from Zoo Keeper, which
is one of the systems we use
in the back-end, we get two
futures back.
Each one of those futures, the
first one gives us the data,
and the second one gives
us notifications
once the data changes.
And that means that you
basically have different paths
that your code has to
deal with, right?
You have the first future that
may fire, you have the second
one, and you have the path that
is the function that is
currently executing.
But all of that is a single
algorithm so we have to take
those three features and have to
put them back into a single
logic that makes sense.
Go gives us a very
straightforward path for that.
You can just say give me a
watch, it can block until the
data comes back, and the channel
actually gives you a
good way to wait for that
information as well in line,
without having to go out.
I don't have time to go
over each detail.
Changing a language for a
project from one side to the
other is a very important
decision.
There are many, many small bits
that would take a full
talk to go over.
So this is basically
what we're doing.
If you want more information,
please, this is the URL.
Andrew, thank you.
ANDREW GERRAND: Thanks,
Gustavo.
So my next speaker is one of the
first engineers at Heroku,
and didn't respond to my
request to send me a
biography, and is also
a great guy.
Please welcome Keith Rarick.
KEITH RARICK: Thanks, Andrew.
I'd like to give you a quick
story about one of the first
production systems that we
used Go for at Heroku.
So first of all what's Heroku?
For those of you who haven't
looked at it before, it's a
platform as a service for
running primarily web
applications.
It started out just as Ruby on
Rails, but these days you can
run just anything,
including Go.
Right now we have about 1.9
million apps, and the company
itself has about 85 employees.
How Heroku works, just in a
super short nutshell is each
app runs as a handful, one or
more lightweight containers
that we call dynos.
And one of the most important
pieces of Heroku is our HTTP
front end routing service.
It has to have a table of all
the processes that are running
and where they are at any
moment, so that it can handle
incoming user requests and send
them to the right place.
And of course it changes
whenever
processes start and stop.
For example, when a user scales
up to more dynos.
Now not all of these 1.9 millio
apps are actually
active at any moment, but a
significant fraction are.
And of course it's changing
all the time.
The way we've implemented this
is we have a service to store
just the routing table.
It keeps the canonical copy of
this table in a Postgres
database, and it was originally
written in Ruby as
a RESTful HTTP sort of API in
front of this database.
So whenever the Process Manager
starts or stops a
process, it makes a call
to this service
to update its record.
And then on the other side,
whenever we start up a new
instance of the front end
router, it connects into the
service, gets an initial JSON
dump of the entire table, and
then after that, streaming
updates.
So it saves in the sync.
So here's a picture of roughly
what that looks like.
Things go in from the left and
come out on the right.
And this works pretty great,
especially because each front
end router has a complete copy
of the table in memory, so it
can do fast look ups with no
IPC or anything like that.
But there's a problem, and
that's just that bootstrapping
a new instance of the
front end router is
prohibitively slow.
And it turns out that that's
just because of the process
generating, the Ruby process
generating this
initial JSON dump.
So the guy who's working on this
project, he had already
used Go for a couple of
experiments on smaller things.
And he decided it might be worth
taking a look to see if
it would help out in
the situation.
So he decided he just wanted to
make a drop in replacement
for the piece that generates
the dump of the table and
sends out streaming updates.
And the nice thing was that he
felt like he could just mess
around in an afternoon to get a
good feel for whether or not
it would work out.
And in just a couple of hours,
he had a working prototype
which was very encouraging, so
we decided to go ahead and
make it into a real, clean it
up and go through our normal
testing and staging procedures,
and so we finally
deployed it to production,
initially alongside the
existing Ruby process.
But here's the new picture with
the Go piece in place.
And after running it for
a while and getting
operationally comfortable
with this new piece,
we flipped the switch.
This was some time ago, so that
the Go process is now the
canonical one.
And honestly, it was pretty
much a win all around.
First of all, it solved the
initial problem that we set
out to solve with more
than a 10x speedup
generating that dump.
And in addition to that, it's
just the ops burden is
actually significantly less.
We can just take that single
binary and throw it up on a
server, and it's easy to run,
it's easy to manage.
And that's actually been sort of
a recurring theme, sort of
overall at Heroku.
We've seen people sort of start
to play around with Go a
little bit on some smaller
things, or
just on a side project.
And then we've sort of adopted
it for more and more things
actually in production.
So now we have a handful of
systems running in production.
And there's several more on
the way, in the pipeline.
Thanks.
ANDREW GERRAND: Thank
you, Keith.
So my next guest has written
software for heart devices,
video games, online dating
systems and mobile apps.
Formally the CTO of
OK Cupid, he's now
the founder of StatHat.
Please, oh.
I've done in the wrong order.
Oh my God.
Since I've introduced
him, he can start.
Please welcome Patrick Crosby.
PATRICK CROSBY: We've all
listened to our talks so much,
I probably could have
done Evan's.
So StatHat as a service to
track statistics in your
applications, you can
add one line of
code and you get graphs.
You can track alerts and embed
charts on your own site.
For example, say you have
an online dating site.
One good metric to see if you
have an effective site is to
track if the user gets a
reply to their message.
So if you do something like
change the matching algorithm
and the reply counts
go up, then--
thank you--
then the matching algorithm
has gotten better, and
StatHat's perfect for tracking
something like this.
So this how you would track
reply counts in the 15
different languages
we support.
We have Go, Ruby, Python, and
all the rest of these.
Once you add that one line, you
get time charts showing
the value changing over time,
histograms showing the
distribution of the data,
and you can embed
charts in any site.
This is example from GitHub
archive where they're tracking
every single GitHub event, and
they show a StatHat chart on
their main site.
So you can track anything.
Here's a bunch of examples, but
basically any number in
your code, any count, any event
you can send to StatHat.
Almost everything in StatHat's
written in Go.
We use a standard net HTTP
package for our web and data
collection.
Our back-end all communicates
over RPC, and we use a ton of
third party and standard
packages.
We often get asked
why we chose Go.
The main reasons is
that it's fast.
Our services and request
times are very low.
And it's also fast to develop,
and because it's statically
typed, we don't have to write
as many unit tests.
It's also very resource
friendly.
Our server costs are much
less than if we used
something like Rails.
It's an easy to deploy
system, which I'll
talk about in a bit.
And it's also a fun language
to spend your
time coding all day.
So a brief overview of
our architecture.
So the stat we talked about
before, the message reply
count comes in over HTTP to our
data collection servers,
and it gets sent over RPC
to the dataset services.
And the user interacting with
the web service gets all the
components from the various RPC
services, and then we have
some other Go applications
that send
alerts and email reports.
Here's some details of the
data collection service.
Once the stack comes in over
HTTP, it gets put in the cache
right away, and we respond to
the caller as soon as we can.
Then there's a Go routine that
serializes this cache to disk
in case the server crashes, and
another Go routine that
takes data out of the
cache and puts it
in the update channel.
We then have a pool of hundreds
of Go routines that
takes data out of the update
channel and sends it over RPC
to the dataset services.
So deployment of Go applications
is very easy, and
the main reason is the binaries
are self-contained,
so there's no shared
libraries, gems or
dependencies you have
to worry about.
And the Go tool also downloads
any third party packages for
you and installs them.
So basically if you can get
your app to compile,
you can deploy it.
At StatHat, every time we do
a get push it starts the
deployment process.
What this entails is it pulls
all the code, runs all the
tests, and compiles all
of our applications.
If all of that works, it then
makes a bundle and adds all
the content resources.
And then we have a web service
where we select the servers
that are supposed to receive
this bundle, and just rsyncs
the bundle over and tells them
that they have a new bundle
and they should restart
anything.
And these servers don't have
Go installed, they're just
basic Linux installations.
And this whole process to make
the bundle takes about two
minutes, and it's 100,000
lines of code.
StatHat's an invitation only
service, but if you go to
stathat.com/io2012 you can sign
up without an invite, and
we also have some open source
go code at stathat.com/src.
Thank you.
ANDREW GERRAND: Thanks,
Patrick.
And I'll just jump back in my
slides to the right spot.
I hope.
All right.
So my final guest is the lead
engineer at Iron.io.
He was an early Go contributor
and contributed to the FastCGI
and SMTP packages, and is now
working on a book called Go In
Action from Manning
publishing, please
welcome Evan Shaw.
EVAN SHAW: Hi, I'm just going
to talk a little bit about
Iron.io and what we do, and
how we're using Go.
So Iron.io builds cloud
application services, that is
we build applications on top
of cloud platforms like AWS
and Rackspace, maybe Google
compute engine in the future.
And our main goal is to remove
infrastructure worries.
So most companies have a small
set of problems that they want
to focus on, and infrastructure
is usually not
one of those problems.
And once we can remove these
worries, we can enable smaller
teams to do bigger things,
which is another
major goal of ours.
So the first product we came out
with is called IronWorker.
It's a massively parallel
worker platform.
So you upload your code or
binary, and then start sending
us task data or payloads, and
for each one of those you send
us, we'll queue a task,
and then run it in
our pool server somewhere.
Our API for the service was
originally written with Ruby
on Rails, but it wasn't really
keeping up with demand, not
scaling how we wanted to.
So we wrote version two in Go,
and that made it a lot faster.
We were able to take our roughly
30 Ruby servers and
condense them down to
two Go servers.
And the second one is mostly
for redundancy.
We have a couple other products
written in Go.
One is IronMQ, a scalable
message queue.
It runs underneath IronWorker
and sends all your task data
to the runners.
And then IronCache, which is
our latest product, it's a
distributed key value store.
Both of these have RESTful HTTP
APIs and text protocol
support, being stock in the case
of IronMQ and memchache
in the case of IronCache.
So here's just an illustration
of the flow of data through
IronWorker and IronMQ.
You send it an HTTP request to
go through the API, and then
we do a little processing there
and put it on IronMQ.
And we have all these runners,
which is what we call the
servers that actually run the
job, polling tasks off of this
queue, and then running them.
So we serve a lot of HTTP
requests in Iron.io using Go,
and the strategy that we use to
serve those is generally by
composing HTTP handlers
together into a chain.
So the first handler in
the chain is typically
authentication.
We decide whether the request
shold be able to continue, and
if not, it's unauthorized.
It if it is able to continue,
it delegates to the next
handler in the chain.
Then we do something similar
with statistics and usage.
So each one of these handlers
has a very specific purpose,
and then it delegates onto the
next handler until it gets to
the end, which does the
validation of the request and
the database operations, and
finally serves the response.
We don't use a lot of
concurrency directly in our
applications, but that's really
kind of a testament to
the good design of
the Go libraries.
So the HTTP package
automatically serves requests
in separate Go routines for us,
we just have to make sure
that our handlers aren't sharing
any state that's not
synchronized.
For text protocols, we do run
separate Go routines for each
client, which doesn't require
much communication.
But we automatically get
Asynchronous I/O with that,
which is really awesome.
If we were writing this in
node js we would have all
these callbacks while
we waited for
operations to complete.
Or if we were writing it in C
or C++ we would have to mess
with [? e-poll. ?]
It's just a big pain, but Go
takes care of that for us in
the libraries, and we can just
write code the way we
want to write it.
So one other place we use
concurrency is as kind of an
optimization.
Sometimes you have these
actions in the request,
response path that don't
actually need to be completed
by the time you serve
the response.
So we can move those into
a separate Go routine.
Even less critical things can
just have a dedicated go
routine that's kind of running
in the background, gathering
up all this information and
patching it together into one
request or one database update,
or whatever it is.
So as an example of that first
point, we have here an HTTP
handler that is getting a
project ID and then updating
some statistics related
to that project ID.
And this is a somewhat
expensive operation,
noticeable if we keep it in
the request response path.
So in the after code, we've
moved that into an anonymous
function, put Go at the front,
and made it into a call.
And now that code runs in a
separate Go routine, and it
greatly reduces the latency
of this request.
And this is something that's
really cheap and easy to do,
and we've hardly even
changed the code.
It looks almost the same.
So why do we use Go?
Well for one, it's fast.
It right not only runs fast,
but it compiles quickly.
And I've worked on projects
that take 45 minutes or an
hour to compile, and
it's not fun.
It's still fairly expressive
for a compiled, statically
typed language.
You don't tend to miss features
from languages like
Ruby and Python.
It has a very rich
standard library.
If you wanted to operate with
formats like JSON or protocols
like HTTP and other languages,
you might have to enlist in a
third party or non-standard
library to get things done.
But almost everything
we need is
built into the Go libraries.
It's not tied to a VM, which
makes deployment really easy.
Go compiles static binaries with
no dependencies, so you
just drop it on a server,
run it, and that's it.
Nothing to really think about.
And finally, Go is awesome.
We have a lot of
fun writing Go.
And so I hope if you were
harboring any doubts about
using Go in production before
this presentation, we've kind
of helped dispel those doubts.
Thank you.
ANDREW GERRAND: Thanks.
All right, so now I've invited
to the others back on stage,
and if anybody would like to
step up to the mic and ask
questions to our panelists,
we'd be more than happy to
answer them.
First person to do so gets
a Go [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: The guy from
Heroku, one question.
Keith.
You're using Erlang as well at
Heroku, and then what do you
use rather Erlang versus Go?
Because both languages do
concurrency correctly, they're
one of the few languages that
doesn't suck when it comes to
writing [? an array ?] of
concurrent software and
reliable software.
KEITH RARICK: So how do we
decide whether to use Erlang
or Go for any given project?
It's mostly up to whoever's
working on the project.
The most well known thing that
we have in Erlang is the
actual HTTP front end routers
that I was mentioning earlier,
those are all written
in Erlang.
I guess the biggest reason for
those is that that project was
started before, I believe
before Go even existed.
Certainly before it was
publicly available.
And the team that maintains it,
they like Erlang and they
don't feel like rewriting
the whole thing.
But yeah, it's pretty much
a personal choice.
I don't think we've
started many new
projects in Erlang lately.
AUDIENCE: So why?
KEITH RARICK: Why?
Well, it's hard to find
Erlang developers.
AUDIENCE: So Go might be a
bit more approachable to
developers than compared
to Erlang.
KEITH RARICK: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
ANDREW GERRAND: Maybe you could
say a little bit, maybe
each of you could say a little
bit about your experience
bringing new developers
up to speed with Go.
Leading on from there.
Someone.
EVAN SHAW: Okay, I'll Go.
Should I talk about hiring
Go developers as well?
ANDREW GERRAND: Sure, whatever's
most interesting.
EVAN SHAW: So since I've been
working on Iron.io, we've had
I think a couple times where
we've tried to hire Go
programmers, and we've
been really
succesful in that so far.
We just put out a job notice
on the [INAUDIBLE], and I
think within two days we had
between [INAUDIBLE].
Some, not so good, but others
very good, to the point where
we had to pool some time
deciding who to hire.
So, no concern there.
We've also had a couple of
developers who did not have
any Go experience, or did not
have much Go experience come
in, and we found it very easy to
get them up to speed on how
Go works, and [INAUDIBLE].
GUSTAVO NIEMEYER: After this
talk, it's probably going to
get harder to find people.
KEITH RARICK: Yeah, I just
wanted to add that something
that I've seen over and over
again is talking with people
who are looking at Go or
thinking about it, or maybe
they haven't even really looked
at it carefully, but
you can talk to them about a new
language, especially Go.
You can show them some examples,
or you can say, oh,
look, it has all these great
features, and it's easy to
deploy, and all this stuff.
But then if you can get someone
to actually sit down
and write a page of code, spend
10 minutes actually
using it, that's a whole
different story.
Then the light bulbs start going
off, and then they are
going on, and then they really
start to appreciate it.
But until that moment, that's
usually a big turning point.
It's like people look at it,
and they go, oh, that looks
interesting, it's pretty cool,
and then they forget about it.
And then you do it again,
and they give
you the same response.
But then when they actually
start using it, then it's
pretty different.
GUSTAVO NIEMEYER: At Canonical,
it's been quite a
ride as well.
Even more if you have a good
development body in the company.
It's not straightforward to
just switch languages.
People are, sometimes they're
passionate about the language.
Sometimes they're unwilling,
they just don't have the time
to try something new.
I personally find people all
over the place, but I share as
well Keith's feeling that when
people do take the time to
experiment with it, and have
an open mind about the
benefits of developing it, I do
see people switching over
and getting closer
to the language.
ANDREW GERRAND: Wanna
take this question?
AUDIENCE: One of the common
recurring themes we heard was
that we used to use Ruby, and so
I was wondering what's the
Rails of Go, and what do you
guys think about the packages,
and Ruby has a really huge
community, and a lot of
different gems, and what do
you guys think about the
community around Go?
ANDREW GERRAND: So that's kind
of two questions there.
Maybe Patrick's best suited to
answering about doing front
end development with Go, because
I know his entire
stack is written in Go.
PATRICK CROSBY: We did have a
prototype that was in Rails,
and we were worried about
switching mainly because of
the plug-ins.
We didn't want to write user
authentication again.
But then it actually took about
an afternoon to write
the equivalent of [INAUDIBLE] in
Go, and so we haven't been
spending our time on
stuff like that.
But it's actually very easy.
The net HTTP package is great.
All you do is provide a function
that handles a route,
and the template package is
incredibly fast compared to
ERB or something.
So I wouldn't hesitate
to try it.
And I don't think there's a
Rails, there's a few other
third party packages for
providing web services, but
the standard net HTTP
works great for us.
ANDREW GERRAND: And do
any of you want to
speak to the Go community?
The size of standard
[INAUDIBLE]?
Well I know I know that at least
a few people here are
active members of it.
GUSTAVO NIEMEYER: So the Go
community, in a way it's like
we are the Go community
as well.
ANDREW GERRAND: Not in total.
GUSTAVO NIEMEYER: Well, it's
been growing, right?
The packages are just like
any other language.
The quality of the packages
are all over the place.
The number of packages, we have
quite a few of those.
The core packages for our
development, we pretty much
find what we want, or we develop
the missing pieces
somewhat easily as well.
In terms of the question about
Rails, or which platform to
use, I share Patrick's
view as well.
The standard library is
really good as well.
The HTTP package, for instance,
it's unlike other
languages we've tried.
ANDREW GERRAND: And I think the
man in the glasses of at
back there has a question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
One of the questions I've
heard from people when I
prophecise about Go is whether
having a mark-and-sweep
garbage collector in a systems
language makes any sense.
And I pushed back a little
bit, obviously.
But I'm wondering if you guys
have actually, using it in
production, can talk about
whether having a garbage
collector in that language is an
issue for you guys or not.
I'm just curious.
PATRICK CROSBY: It has not.
The only issue we had is there
is a bug using 32-bit servers
with garbage collection.
But once we found out that there
was a bug and switched
to 64-bit servers, we haven't
had any problem with garbage
collection.
ANDREW GERRAND: And it's worth
noting that that issue is
within a few weeks of being
fixed entirely.
KEITH RARICK: One thing that I
can say is we haven't yet used
Go for anything that's highly
sensitive to latency, but
Heroku has a lot of pieces
inside, a lot of different
components that were running in
production, and honestly,
very few of them are actually
that latency sensitive.
One example is something like
again, this front end HTTP
router that handles user
requests, that matters.
It matters that when a request
comes in, it's not waiting for
a GC pause.
But relatively few pieces
actually depend on that
particular kind of performance
sensitivity.
So for most things that we're
doing, it's batch operations,
it's background tasks, and
it's not a big deal.
ANDREW GERRAND: But have you
actually observed any GC
issues in what you're
doing anyway?
KEITH RARICK: No.
GUSTAVO NIEMEYER: I think in
our case it's similar.
We don't have workload with very
low latency requirements.
And I also feel a little bit
like the speed of the
language, the speed in which
everything else executes, like
dwarfs the garbage collection
problems we might have.
And I have to say as well,
that in fact, from some
perspectives I've developed
quite a few [INAUDIBLE]
extensions for Python
to speed things up.
And while the reference counting
could be faster, it
also creates a lot of issues
in terms of leaks that are
really hard to find, and it's
always a hunt going after
what's going on.
So in that regard, we have six
stations as well in at least a
couple of our packages, and we
haven't had any such issues.
So in that sense, the, garbage
collector actually helps us.
ANDREW GERRAND: We'll take
another question.
AUDIENCE: So all of the
presentations said that while
Go is awesome, could you share,
like, some of either
your favorite parts of it,
or maybe things that your
developers, as you've been
wrapping them up are like,
aha, that's so great.
KEITH RARICK: Gofmt.
That is my favorite
part of Go.
ANDREW GERRAND: It's
not a swear word.
Gofmt is the formatting tool
that makes all Go code look
the same, ending all the style
wars about why it's best in
[INAUDIBLE] placement
and so on.
KEITH RARICK: More specifically,
it's not just
that it exists, but that I am
astounded at what a good job
the community has done at sort
of adopting it and sticking
with it, and consistently using
this tool, and never
having to worry about that stuff
again is just, I mean
don't waste that time.
GUSTAVO NIEMEYER: So to
kind of restate what I
said earlier again.
To me there's no single feature
of Go that I find, oh
my God, this is so amazing,
and I've never
seen anything similar.
Perhaps gofmt is a little bit
unlike anything else.
But I think what's really
fantastic about Go and unlike
anything else in my perspective
is precisely the
fact of all the bits together,
how they make sense.
EVAN SHAW: Yeah, I
really agree with
what Gustavo was saying.
It's hard to really single
out any one thing
that makes Go great.
But if you really force
me to do it, I
would say the libraries.
I think of all the languages
I've used, most libraries
[INAUDIBLE]
libraries I've seen.
[INAUDIBLE].
If you are curious about how
something works internally,
it's very easy to dive in and
start reading the code.
It's very accessible
code, and good for
learning code as well.
KEITH RARICK: Yeah, I want
to echo that too.
It's just systemic
good design.
ANDREW GERRAND: Thanks.
Next question?
AUDIENCE: So I'm also using Go
on production at SmugMug.
First of all I wanted to say
thanks to everyone, and people
who are on the golang-nuts list,
I read a lot of your
pots, and they're
very helpful.
I mean, personally the thing
for me that I like about Go
the most is it's impossible to
get confused by most Go code.
I can show it to other
people I work with.
It's always very
straightforward, so I
appreciate the fact that there's
been a tendency to
keep it simple.
So two questions I have
for the panel.
One thing I noticed when I
started building the proxy
server I wrote was sort
of a lack of a
standard make like tool.
And there are a lot of them
out there, and I'm just
wondering, and I just went with
shell scripts because I
couldn't really see one
that had traction.
Just wondering if there's a
preference among the panel for
build tools automation.
PATRICK CROSBY: I think a lot of
that's changed since Go 1.
Go install basically does
everything for you.
We use that just go install
StatHat basically.
GUSTAVO NIEMEYER: It's not even
just the building part,
there's a good, consistent
scheme in which
libraries are organized.
They're fetched from the network
as well, so you can
do, like, goget and URL all with
the command, and you get
the command running.
Even though it has dependencies,
it has build
tools, so I find
it pretty good.
ANDREW GERRAND: Yeah, but what
they're referring to is, for
those who aren't familiar, is
this Go tool that ships with
the Go tool chain, that's just
called Go and there are
various verbs like gobuild,
gotest, goinstall,
gofmt, and so on.
AUDIENCE: So my second question
was if there's
anything from the libraries
you think is missing that
you'd really like to see.
GUSTAVO NIEMEYER: There are
certain things I'd like to see
better done, perhaps.
Like SSH package is one that is
evolving, but it's complex
to get something that really
works across all the cases in
a consistent and stable way.
So I appreciate the package.
I want to see it being
polished over time.
ANDREW GERRAND: Thanks.
Take the next question.
AUDIENCE: So this is just from
the Google moderator, which is
linked to from the screen.
So Jason asked, and
you might have
covered this early, actually.
Can you talk about how long
it would take to learn Go?
ANDREW GERRAND: How long does
it take to learn Go?
KEITH RARICK: I know I referred
to someone to the Go
tour who wanted to learn Go, and
they learned it within a
few weeks, and they're now
working somewhere programming
Go every day.
GUSTAVO NIEMEYER: So this is a
tricky question, I find as
well, personally at least.
I find that I never
stop learning.
I'm still learning Go as well,
even though I've started a
couple of years ago, and I hope
I don't stop learning.
People can get up to speed with
the basic language and
productive as Keith
was saying.
And if you're proficient with
language, in just a few
minutes you're going to
be doing something.
It's going to take a little bit
longer for you to get used
to the conventions and what it
takes to get a feeling for
what is Go proper,
and it's learning
to program in general.
It's a lifelong task, I think.
ANDREW GERRAND: Thanks,
next question?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was wondering if you guys
could share your experiences
with other parts of the
development tooling, like
debuggers, profilers,
even ID support.
how easy is to work with and
use, and help solve real
problems, that kind of thing?
KEITH RARICK: I can just
comment briefly.
When working on Doozer, the Go
Profiler was invaluable.
It's one of the things that, I
don't have a whole lot to say
about it, but it was nice.
It was pretty easy to use, and
told me what I need to know.
ANDREW GERRAND: So the profiler
that comes with Go is
a very intuitive pprof which is
a C++ profiling tool that
Google built, and it provides
graphs of memory allocations,
and also CPU utilization in
a core graph kind of cell.
KEITH RARICK: And one of my
coworkers also said that he
was very happy with the
GDP integration.
He was pleasantly surprised.
And if you know him, that's
an understatement.
He was pleasantly surprised that
it just worked, and it
and it was really,
really well.
Nicely done.
ANDREW GERRAND: Take
another question.
AUDIENCE: Another moderator
question from Josh.
What books on Go would
you recommend?
PATRICK CROSBY: Golang.org.
Sorry, I haven't actually
read any other Go books,
but it's a good site.
EVAN SHAW: I haven't read any
Go books either, but I will
point out again that
I'm writing one.
GUSTAVO NIEMEYER: Sorry.
ANDREW GERRAND: Thanks,
Gustavo.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
First I'd like to congratulate
the Go team on making
something simple enough that the
most interesting thing you
can do is write useful code,
which I think is a pretty
impressive achievement.
So I'm first interested in any
advice you might have for
people looking to deploy Go
potentially into a high
traffic environment, in terms
of for instance, like
segmented stacks.
But boundaries, trying to
avoid going over those.
I know that there might be a
performance issue associated
with that, or Scheduler
being rather young.
Are there any words of wisdom
to avoid unforeseen
consequences?
ANDREW GERRAND: Do you mean like
to avoid trouble spots,
essentially?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, performance
or reliability gotchas,
effectively.
ANDREW GERRAND: Maybe you can
speak to it, but I was just
going to say the general
approach that I've seen inside
Google is just write the
simplest code that is
obviously correct, and then if
things start going pear shaped
profile, and that recipe tends
to work pretty well.
KEITH RARICK: That's exactly
what I was going to say.
I mean, that's just you do in
general with programming.
Don't worry too much about
performance at first, just
write it correctly.
And then if you have performance
problems, fix
them, but only the places that
you actually need to.
Just profile.
GUSTAVO NIEMEYER: It's good as
well to have a good idea of
what operations take the basic
timing of operations, right?
Because after you learn that,
then you don't worry as much
because you know what are the
obvious things that will take
a long time.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Everything works as expected.
Cool.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Having used and worked
with Go for a while,
how do you feel about using it
in, like, offline desktop type
applications?
KEITH RARICK: So this is one
of the most fun recent
projects that I've worked
on at Heroku.
So we have a command line tool
called Heroku that has existed
since the beginning of Heroku,
that we use, that all of our
users use to interact with the
system, to create new apps and
to change their environment
variables, and do all that
sort of stuff.
It's one of those projects that
it's been around for a
long time, and it's quite a bit
of code, and for a long
time, and so now it's
well maintained.
It has a great maintainer who's
done a lot of good work,
but for a long time it sort of
floated around without a clear
owner, and it sort of a
accumulated a whole lot of
code, and it got really
slow and bloated, and
it wasn't very fun.
And so one of the things that
another coworker did to sort
of jumpstart, or at least
compete a little bit and
motivate work on the official
command line tool is to make
an alternative in Go
just for speed.
So there's a tool out there, you
can find it on my GitHub,
and it's called HK, and
it's very simple.
It's very similar to the
existing Heroku tool, except
it's written in Go.
And there are a couple of other
nice things, too, like
the fact that it's a single
binary means that the
installation instructions
are simple.
You just curl this file down and
stick it in the directory,
and you've got it installed.
There's no downloading all
these packages and
dependencies and stuff
like that.
And in fact, because it's just
a single binary, it took
literally an evening for me to
write a self update feature,
including a nice binary diff
so that the updates are a
tenth of the size that they
would otherwise be.
And so it can periodically check
to see if there's an
update, and download the update,
and apply the patch,
and ask you if you'd like to,
yes, do you want this update?
And then it just renamed the
file over top, and it's great.
ANDREW GERRAND: I think the
process you were describing is
trolling driven development.
KEITH RARICK: Yes, that's
what he called it.
Trolling driven development.
ANDREW GERRAND: Rewrite
the bad stuff in Go.
Do any of you have any thoughts
on, like, GUI stuff,
because I said desktop
applications.
I guess none of you are really
working on them.
EVAN SHAW: I think where Go is
really strong right now is in
the server back-end area.
I would really like to see
desktop graphical applications
written to Go.
But I think the library bindings
are still young and
there's at least one effort to
write a graphical toolkit in
Go itself, which is really
interesting.
But that's young as well.
And yeah, I recently saw
somebody was [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW GERRAND: There's
actually been
more than one game.
There's a few over the years.
GUSTAVO NIEMEYER: I think
I agree with what you
just said as well.
I'm pretty excited about being
able to use a graphical
toolkit in Go.
I don't think the toolkits are
quite there yet, but the
concepts that Go allows us to
use, they do make sense in a
graphical application as well.
So the concurrency aspects, the
way that you can handle
information asynchronously while
waiting for data and
channels and so on.
this It's usable in graphical
applications as well.
ANDREW GERRAND: Great, are there
any other questions?
All right, well thanks everybody
for coming along.
And thank you very much
to our guests.
If we could give them a warm
round of applause.